she starts applauding him going good job
we're good for you which is worse
and she just goes oh good for you super
disrespectful i'm like okay first of all
number one i did not applaud
because i had riley to carry
but i did say good for you
as if you're pitying him like he's a
see that's this is where he fabricates
the story because i know i didn't
applaud because i had riley to hold most
in five
four what was all three
no i didn't do anything yet why are you
laughing it's your face
should i get sucked
what do you mean one hello everybody
what i mean by that is i'm going to sock
you in the face
don't miss you have to redo this whole
thing here we go in five okay what
what's going on i don't know
you know you know how the show works
okay in five oh hold on why are you
yelling relax what do you have
let's do it again eat on and if you
interrupt me one more time it's going to
be a fist fight outside
why are you so violent shut up
my brain farts need the intro to be
correct if not they can't focus on the
podcast all right
i'll be stepping
in five
four
three
two
one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
namaste
i'm i'm focusing right now namaste
hello how dare you interrupt the genius
podcast i've ever done any kind of yeah
you look like you're going to read me a
bedtime story it is late at night i'm
ready to wind down it's not that cold in
the house for you to have that blanket
yes i'm sorry the past few months who's
the one who kept turning on the heater
when i thought it was pretty warm
so
shut the hell up well it's pretty cool
today you know what's interesting what
we just saw actually uh not too long ago
we saw this documentary she was on this
weird documentary binge and i'll tell
you this one documentary that i probably
never ever would ever care to see was
the paris hilton doctor me too
which is so fascinating right
first of all i i think
the paris hilton documentary is kind of
shitty just because
90 of it is that so they kind of lead on
in the beginning of the documentary
telling you that there's one thing that
you don't know about paris hilton right
and so throughout the whole documentary
you're waiting to hear this thing and
they tell it to you probably at the last
20 minutes basically dave and i are
watching it we're halfway through and
david got sick of it and he got a call
so he literally halfway through it was
like 45 minutes through yeah and he
comes back later after i finish watching
it and he's like so what happened i was
like the last 10 minutes what we re when
we find out they had nothing else to
talk about that was the thing there's
literally nothing eventful in her life
except for this one thing right and so
they know this they know the audience
knows that the rest of the [ __ ]
the documentary is trying to show us
that paris hilton is actually she goes
through real people problems but they do
a terrible job of portraying it
throughout the whole [ __ ] series i
have to keep working because i want to
become a billionaire yeah so
it's interesting because when you have
somebody who is so far removed from
regular society and i'm talking about
she is in like the half percenter of the
world i'm talking about it doesn't
matter what she does she has such an
unlimited amount of money it doesn't
matter and so when she tries to do this
thing where she's you know she's
portraying this thing of like listen i'm
just a normal person like everybody else
and this is just a whole facade but
everything that she does isn't really
normal compared to the rest of the world
yeah like how she views how she can do
things
at a whim is simply just done because
she has an absorbent amount of money
yeah like even this one little phrase
that she said she goes she goes i can't
rest until i become a billionaire
because if i have a billion dollars then
i then i know that financially i'll be
stable
that's basically what she was alluding
to i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you [ __ ] rich
psychopath she well she was saying later
on that she thinks she'll be happy then
so like as you're progressing you're
they kind of ask that same question a
different way and you could see that
it's slowing to change because in the
beginning it's like uh financially i
want to be stable and then later i was
just like i want to be happy and then
towards the end when we see everything
she goes to her closet which is massive
looks around she's like you know what to
be honest this is just putting a
character like i don't give a f about
any of these stuff that i have all these
materials
so you start to see that she is telling
the truth later on at the end of the
document documentary but then i felt
like we were already like exhausted
we're like this is
it seemed very disingenuous you know
what i mean it seems like she was saying
it as lip service because she wanted
people to feel like listen i don't need
any of this stuff like i'm i figured out
that the meaning of life isn't my
possessions but they asked like oh
you're you're done you don't have to do
this stuff and say would you give it up
she goes no no because she loves it
she's addicted to she's addicted to the
attention and so what the thing is like
her lifestyle isn't based on whether oh
i need these things because i need to
make money because the money gives her
value and worth it's no i need attention
if i don't go outside and people don't
recognize me i'll die that's how she
feels and she tries her best to kind of
hide it throughout the whole docu-series
where she's putting on this
it's funny because there's two sides to
her right
in the docuseries she's trying to show
like listen
this whole jessica simpson i'm stupid i
don't know what's going on thing is it's
completely false it's a persona that i'm
putting on because of something that
i've created so i could become the
social media star yeah right but the
funny thing is if there's a double part
it's like yeah that's a fake put on
stuff but you being a wholesome
down-to-earth person where you're not
you don't need material things
it's not right now it's part of you it's
a part of you like you can't step away
from it so the real thing is it's like
what it really boils down to is that she
lives off of attention
and it's crazy like i didn't really
think about this but they said it in the
documentary paris hilton and this is
according to her manager and what she
says and i agree
there was never really an idea of what
an influencer was like what the [ __ ] is
an influencer
seven years ago six years maybe even
four years ago if you ask somebody
hey what do you do for a living and they
go i'm an influencer i'd be like what
the heck what the [ __ ] are you talking
about i said what do you do for a living
they go i influence what is an
influencer and really goes back to
parish hilton because when you look at
what paris hilton did right what did
paris hilton do
nothing
she was just the heiress to the hilton
hotel yeah she was a rich rich girl and
she had this reality television show
which you guys saw which a lot of people
don't know
kim kardashian
took notes from paris hilton and then
she started her own i know the
kardashian reality show it's crazy which
showed this rich person who's completely
out of touch and they're going through
rich people problems and really i
believe why we thought that that show
was really fascinating is because we
don't know what it's like to be
them
and that's what made it fascinating you
kind of make fun of them you think
they're dumb they're stupid but at the
same time they're kind of putting on
this persona they kind of play it up
because they like the attack do you
think because there wasn't such thing
out there right she's someone who
started it and she knew she was doing
something
does that make her
somewhat in a genius world then that the
fact that she was seeing a potential on
this see everybody uses that that thing
genius right just because they they
guarded a certain level of success doing
something that
it's stupid but makes them a lot of
money they go there's a whole trend on
it and they go that's genius but is it
really though i think it's a little bit
of like
it wasn't a big foresight it's just
something that they really enjoy which
is attention it's i will do anything i
can to make sure people know who i am
like bad boy then yeah like is that
necessarily genius i don't really think
so right i think that's there's them
being so thirsty they'll do literally
whatever people can think they're dumb
stupid it doesn't matter as long as
people know me
i find value based on the fact that i am
recognized i am a valuable person
because people know who i am not that i
am valuable and people know me two
different things
right because you saw in that
documentary at the end she doesn't want
to give any of this up because she loves
the fame and the attention yeah her
value as a person isn't i am a valuable
person because i can offer something
it's i'm only valuable because you guys
say that i am
which is something i own it's kind of
sad but it is sad you know and and the
thing is too throughout the whole thing
like you see her kind of switch between
two personalities paris hilton goes in
and she goes
hey guys oh my god that's so hot that's
so hot it's amazing i love it oh my god
what are you doing
you know and the stuff that she's
stressing out about on the show i think
they're trying to dramatize it to make
it seem like she's going through like
this anxiety [ __ ] but it's literally
first world problems and it's really
hard to connect to it was it was paris
is always [ __ ] she's always late to
[ __ ] and like she's just in her own
world she didn't [ __ ] count she's
working all day and then the manager or
someone said
you're gonna have to get ready by eight
and then they were just like making that
scene so dramatic like it's super
dramatic yeah as if like no celebrities
out there have done that or just human
beings yeah humans like parents mom mom
work
till like midnight and then just to wake
up at five to get the kids ready like
and the biggest reason why it shows that
she's not a down-to-earth person is
because these are regular problems that
everybody deals with yeah but the way
that she handles it she acts as if her
whole world is crumbling and in the
documentary she's trying to make it seem
like listen i i stress out too it's like
those aren't [ __ ]
normal people problems listen
i never want to like be dismissive of
how people feel when they're going
through stressful stuff right she is
working hard yeah but that's also
relative to who your audience is right
so if she's complaining to her rich
friends about rich people [ __ ] rich
people who claim about their rich people
[ __ ] they understand what they're
talking about because in all in all
honesty most of those stuff isn't that
stressful compared to the most of the
stuff that people deal with every day
but when you show that to somebody like
us who are just regular folk we're like
what the [ __ ] are you complaining about
like what is this nonsense
you know yeah
it's i mean for me when i saw that i was
like oh at least because for me and
other
point of view i was just like wow she
really doesn't i thought she didn't go
through anything then i saw that i was
like okay so she's like normal people
she actually works really hard it's just
not given to her everybody goes through
their stuff you know
you know she obviously she's had a leg
up
obviously all the money and all the
connects allowed her to do what she did
but she continued it and she built her
own empire right which is cool right she
is the original influencer yeah um if
you guys want to watch the doc i suggest
you not i'll just tell you what happened
to her what
just watch it it's on youtube well you
can watch it on youtube most likely you
guys are gonna be just like what the
[ __ ] you're gonna be rolling your eyes
but well watch the last
20 minutes 20 minutes so the trauma that
she went through on the documentary i'm
going to spoil it for you guys either
way you guys you're going to want me to
spoil it
so
she she basically went to this camp what
was it for it was it's like something
like fat cats
oh it's for disciplinary so anyone who
camp kind of stuff kind of for
disciplining because these are rich kids
i don't know if it's for rich kids but
i'm assuming with some kind of finance
because it's expensive i looked it up
it's
like you know the name of it i can't
remember but when i was looking it up it
was like some really really expensive so
if you have bad behavior and the parents
cannot control that and doesn't know
what to do then they will hit them up
and then they will bring
basically you go to their school
quote-unquote school and get disciplined
it's what it's essentially rich people
boot camp right so it's
really expensive boot camp so it's for
all these like spoiled rich kids who
think that their life is absolutely
terrible and they send them to this boot
camp to straighten them up well the
thing about this place is completely
closed now because they were abusing the
[ __ ] out of these kids and they're all
girls yeah they were they would watch
them shower um paris tried to escape
multiple times they when they caught her
they beat her ass they did all this like
other stuff yeah they isolated her in
the documentary they said she said that
they
took her clothes off and isolate her in
a room for over a day yeah exactly and
so when we heard this i was like damn
that's [ __ ] crazy that's nice they
waited an hour and a half to tell us
because that was the only thing that you
could say that would make that would
make the documentary make sense because
if they put that in the middle they had
no other material because everything
else that you see in the documentary is
simply her choosing to do the stuff that
she does she doesn't want to take
personal responsibility couldn't they
make it shorter you know then then there
will be more impact yeah actually they
could have made that doc 35 minutes yeah
like half of whatever they had running
time but
uh
what was i gonna say
that
part was actually quite shocking because
they bring her old classmates come over
and talk about their experience so that
you find out oh it's not because at
first i was wondering is she
exaggerating she must be exaggerating
there's no way and then turns out oh no
everybody went through [ __ ] and i think
that we as an audience feel like she's
exaggerating because of her persona that
she always puts on so you know you kind
of mix in this whole like oh is she
being real is she not you don't really
know
and so you'll see in this documentary
she goes in and out she like code
switches constantly so when she's in the
camera her voice is a lot deeper
right it's a lot more calm and that
she's talking about her [ __ ] and it's
completely fine and she says multiple
times like oh this is like oh i'm just
playing this character she actually
verbally says it like i don't know like
20 times i wonder if she says that
because she needs to tell herself
because i i think a certain point she's
like i don't even know if that's me or
not anymore yeah but once again rich
people problems and so
she goes out in public the cameras are
on that's hot oh my god
so what an interesting thing i actually
know somebody who was actually pretty
close friends with her oh yeah
and
um
[Music]
it's weird because people like kim
kardashian and also this other friend of
mine
has also picked up these habits from
paris
is she rich too
how are they friends i don't want to
talk about her finances okay so um
this person very specifically
i only know this to be true and the
documentary didn't shock me is because i
i already knew about this because of
this friend
so
and she took notes and took that page
out of her book and also applied it to
her life so it's very weird so when i
first met this person
by the way the sweetest person you'll
ever meet has a very very
loving and kind heart
and you see her talk
oh my god that's freaking amazing
well you kind of get to know this person
over time and then you can kind of hear
her switch in and out of this i'm like
hold on a second
are you
is this like a a voice that you're
putting on in my head i didn't really
think about this right
and i didn't really panty mine because
she was super nice super sweet and very
kind
so a couple of our other friends
they told me the story where they were
hanging out with her and i didn't know
this but he was telling me like hey
you know that stuff that she does you
know she learned from paris hilton and
it's not it's not really her she's
actually very educated super smart she's
like bilingual everything
and i'm like what the hell are you
talking about and so when they were
hanging out
she was doing her whole
uh valley girl accent and he literally
looks there he goes there's no cameras
here stop yeah just
okay and you know she goes back to her
normal way of speaking
so it's only
it's a specific social media persona and
so that's how i knew that this
documentary is real about that that
paris thing because she learned that
stuff from paris
and it's worked for her it worked for
her very well
and it's kind of crazy to see do you
ever need how hard it is to live like
two personalities in two lives
no it's so
i mean
you you code switch pretty hard so i
think you kind of know no that's
different that's different i'm not you
didn't intentionally do a job
interviewing an australian accent
this podcast is brought to you by fiverr
my friends we all know how hard it is to
make something out of nothing just the
thought of turning that big idea into
reality can feel overwhelming how did
you even get started you get started
with fiverr homie listen i actually use
fiverr for literally just about anything
um graphic design specifically a lot of
illustrations um when i'm looking for an
illustrator or a graphic design that's
within my budget fiverr has
all the people and all the resources
that i need to create the stuff that i
personally can't make when you're a
business owner when you have project
ideas or even if you want to do video
editing
you can't do everything by yourself if
you want to grow your business you need
to hire the right people to help
and cultivate that growth and that's
where fiber freelancers
come in handy it is freaking money it's
just super easy to use every successful
something was once nothing head to
fiverr.com and turn in that nothing into
something today receive 10 off your
first order by using my code geniusbrain
at f i v e r
dot com again that's fiverr as an f i v
e r r.com code genius brain
as i was doing i was like my eyes were
getting big too i was like oh my god i
don't know why this is happening and so
they're like how are you are you like
did you study in australia too and i was
like no but i did have a lot of
australia but i love the shrimp on the
bobby i don't even know what you're
saying crocodile dundee what is shrimp
on the bobby who's bobby
oh my god
prawns on the barbie barbie as in
barbecue
oh i was thinking of like barbie and ken
no
that's so funny i still can't like if i
was interviewing somebody for let's say
june b right
let's say i was the person hiring people
out and then this girl who's talking to
me i'm like oh so why did you want to
apply to joombi like what are your goals
yeah well you know it's like ah
korean accent
i would like you know jimmy's like for
my favorites
matcha is like a japanese but you know
sometimes the japanese are okay
okay i don't also didn't like going to
konglish oh really oh really so we so
i take this
[Laughter]
okay we're mountain so on this hike
trail in near sacramento in this area
called auburn there's this trail called
i can't even say anything lake
clementine take it okay
there's this guy young dude on a
mountain bike and he's mountain biking
right and
in her mind she thinks is a young dude
for some reason but it's an older
gentleman probably like in his 50s maybe
even 60s
she looks at this older man and she goes
she starts applauding him going good job
good for you which is worse
and she just goes oh good for you
super disrespectful i'm like okay
number one i did not applaud
because i had riley to carry
but i did say good for you
as if you're pitying him like he's a
church see that's this is where he
fabricates the story because i know i
didn't applaud because i had riley to
hold mostly but when you retold what you
did you did applaud you went i told them
good for you and i applauded them and i
got away not like oh if you if you would
have saw this guy's face
if you would have saw his face i was
like i wanted to apologize to the guy
why didn't you apologize for that
because i was shocked i was like
yo
how dare you tell this it was like it's
basically you're like oh
that's the equivalent of that is looking
at an older woman and say you actually
look pretty good for your age see
that's not the case because i was
looking at a young gentleman
even if it was a younger gentleman you
shouldn't say good for you
good for you it's very uh i heard it a
lot from mark
so what does that mean no no no when
somebody's doing something that they're
doing you're like good for you it's like
don't
who are you but people i worked so it's
like somebody who you don't even know
and they go i'm proud of you it's like
who the [ __ ] are you well that's
different but it's not you don't know
this person no i'm saying okay so people
at work say it then what does that mean
if you have a relationship and you're
looking at somebody and they go oh
that's dope good for you
you have a relationship so it means
something different this is a stranger
who's just mountain biking and when you
tell them good for you it's like good
for me what i'm just mountain biking are
you saying good for me because of my age
like what does that mean am i old see
that dude's face was so offended he was
like the [ __ ] well he already looked
like he was about to pass out
it was a steep hill that's why i said go
for you because i can't do that it's
it's one of those things tension oh the
attention was great it's just one of
those things that is
you know how languages don't really
directly translate
this is what happens this is why
i don't want to go out
this is exactly why
the intention is right but whatever
comes out of my mouth according to david
is horrifying
well pandemic has definitely caused her
to be a little socially awkward because
he has you know meeting people and
interacting with people is i hate it
very few and far between for example we
went to go get some paperwork done at
like the dmv
right and so
can i tell them yeah go ahead so we were
in front of this window
and there was a clerk
she was a lady i was like kind of
looking around because she was doing her
thing and i was
you know
by default
pre-cover what i would have said to that
lady was like oh my gosh your outfit is
adorable like i really like whatever
you're wearing you know typically a
normal compliment no more compliment but
then my eyes couldn't go to her because
i was like i don't want to make eye
contact so i'm gonna look around what's
around her oh my gosh she got two
monitor arms that's pretty cool she has
a assist stand it's a standing desk uh
and she has an ergonomic chair that's
gnarly she must have a good set up there
so
what did i do she looks at this girl and
this is when i look there's no context
it's a real conversation she just made
it i had it in my hands
your desk is really ergonomic and that
girl paused and she just goes
thank you
she didn't even say thank you she's like
what yeah she didn't know what i was
saying and then she follows up with
look at that printer
she looks at me and she's like do you
see that printer that's a pretty nice
printer i'm like you are the most boring
human being i've ever met you know what
the funny thing is though
before i told you that in my head i was
like i really want to tell him but i
don't think he's going to say i'm a nerd
or he's going to make it he's not even a
nerd it's what what am i supposed to do
he's going to make fun of me
he was going to do this but again i
still had to tell it you ever have a
conversation with somebody and they just
tell you information that you don't know
how to respond back to that is what this
girl is she's the queen of that oh
i have those people we're like standing
there she goes that's a really big
printer and i look at her i'm like
what am i supposed to bounce off of this
how are we supposed to come okay this is
what i was going in my head while i was
talking about the whole ergonomic
setting because that's what all i think
about every day because i'm at my desk i
look at the printer i'm like holy cow
i used that printer every day for
posters um when i was working at disney
and i remember how expensive that
printer is and that was going on like
the whole conversation and i really
wanted to stop tell someone because i
was excited to see i want to try this
let's let's go ahead we're in a time
machine
we're going back in time okay you're
single okay i'm single okay and now okay
we have to flirt
with your social skills now that now
that has dwindled so much we're going to
have to flirt okay but it's not going to
work because we know each other no we
don't okay fine you have to break i
didn't flirt with you oh you flirted
with me i have my other persona you you
okay here it is okay
this is this is the scenario okay
i
i
okay
repeat after me what are you doing right
now i said this is the scenario you
would i i what are you doing
you've already failed listen this is the
scenario okay
i am me
but i am 30 pounds lighter
okay what the [ __ ] i don't understand
why that's hilarious
why did you just keep
okay okay you're 30 pounds lighter 30
pounds lighter okay you're so skinny
hold on a second don't let's not do that
i could have whatever i want no this is
my scenario let me finish okay
i am 30 pounds if you if you laugh one
more time i'm gonna kick you in your
coochie i am i am 30 pounds lighter okay
okay wonderful fade i don't have a
haircut yet i will wonderful haircut we
are at a bar in k-town
you were there
actually dressed like a normal human
being this day
not wearing everything that's uh just
with your dog on it
okay you're gonna wear dorsal she has a
name riley okay excuse me relax
excuse me
continue i'm ordering a drink i look at
you and i go
that little korean girl is kind of cute
i'm gonna order her a drink
excuse me bartender
this is my accent i like the code switch
too okay excuse me bartender
would you give her would you fancy
giving her a little drink
the drink slides over now what do you
say am i alone you are alone you're not
with anybody it's just me and you
excuse me bartender
would you fancy giving the last a little
drink
hmm
i'll take it
cause it's coming from the bartender no
you we're in the scenario don't don't
tell me what you're good
once again
you suck excuse me bart
excuse me bartender i think she would
fancy a drink slides on over to you
now the scenario begins oh
thanks
so what's your name
thrown off a bit so i'll be like oh um
you don't have to narrate women we're in
the scenario just talk to me damn it
excu this is how awkward it's going to
be i'm sorry
excuse me bartender
i think milady would fancy a nice drink
slides on over here we go
thank you
what's your name
marielle where are you from oh you know
you can't tell from my accent no i
cannot what is that accent well a little
bit from here a little bit over there
um so what do you do for living what are
you doing in k-town
i'm just chilling at the bar by myself
are you making fun of my
excuse me excuse me hold on a second are
you are you are you mocking my accent
actually you know what i actually find
that highly offensive are you waiting
where are you you don't have to think
here's the thing what i don't like about
you americans you look
like
do i sound like an american excuse me
your attitude is very american though oh
i i think you're not i haven't dated
europeans and they're a lot more
romantic here have your drink have a
nice night i don't want you i don't walk
away no no no no there you go that's the
funny thing i put a roofie in the drink
you'll be back in five minutes
she took a sip and she knocked out you
don't ever take drinks from me i don't
understand he said that we're going to
talk and so we did but yet he still has
to make the story different why it makes
no the story isn't different we're
supposed to play along but you make fun
of my accent and so i said goodbye
because you're going cray-cray i don't
want to be with a crate why did you mock
my accent i didn't mock your ex you're
you're doing it right now i didn't mock
it i don't excuse me accent you have
listen
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha do you hate the jitters and crash
that coffee gives you well say no more
my friends because hundreds of thousands
of people are drinking jun b matcha not
only for the health benefits but for the
caffeine boost that lasts without the
crash of coffee you can mix it have it
hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have fun with it
remember not all matcha is created the
same and junebe has the highest quality
matcha you can find straight from a farm
in japan hand-picked and curated to get
you the best quality there is no
competition to get 10 off your first
order of tins and packets go to
junebeshop.com that's j-u-n-b-i
shop.com and enter code geniusbrain to
get 10 off your first order that's
j-u-n-b-i-shop.com
code geniusbrain you know what's a very
interesting thing that i wanted to ask
you
what
so recently
listen
she and i have two very different
families
two very opposite families right
i didn't realize how big her family was
see i didn't grow up in i didn't grow up
uh in the united states with a large
family literally the only family members
that i know that i hung out with you
actually met uh jason and mike
and those two are actually my only blood
relatives that are around you know the
kids
that i that i grew up with that i hung
around with other than that everybody
else lives in korea so for us like
growing up so one of the things that i
found out about her is that her family
doesn't really celebrate thanksgiving
and christmas
we did but mainly because
we had a dedicated church that we
attended
and they
you know we have those events there yeah
but those are church we all had those
events we all had church events for
thanksgiving we all had christmas events
that was my event but we still no that
doesn't count but that that was
so your parents i don't understand how
come you well because you're because
your mom is hyper christian so would i
would think that she would want to
celebrate christmas yeah we celebrate
our church
that is so
lazy
literally why would you have to do it
twice if it's already done a trip it's
not it's different that's not really
celebrating christmas that's the church
event that's like saying but that's your
opinion
no that's what it is but that was our
life that was my life is that events
were done at church sometimes
thanksgiving day you celebr you went to
church on thanksgiving day thanks well i
was gonna say
sometimes you cut me off sometimes like
for example thanksgiving day we don't go
to church because it's like thursday so
usually we have it like on the weekends
or fridays
but the day of
most of the time we went to my one of my
aunts house because we would gather all
together with grandma and all the kids
but
even so it wasn't like every year but we
did do it quite often
yeah
but ever since i've been with you you
guys just never celebrated any of this
yeah cause grandma passed away
but your grandma was the binding glute
for everybody to just hang out yes
why
why i don't know
that's a good question
um
because grandma left with my family
uh and i think i think for the sake of
grandma just like so that she could see
all her kids and grandkids and then
obviously
her daughters
which are my aunts they wanted grandma
to see
their grandkids as well it's
so probably that's why
i mean i think we all have the mindset
like we should and we do
and i think we did more or less with the
family while grandma was around but ever
since grandma left
um
the immediate family grew right
everybody got married everybody had
their own kids their own life
and they have their own partner's family
that they have to also take care of and
be part of you know so
obviously the
the energy that they spend on will be
their immediate family not like second
cousins yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't have siblings it's interesting
because the only cousin that you have
that speaks really speaks korean is just
one person yeah and everybody else
doesn't which is so interesting because
usually when it comes to an older
generation of korean people they can
speak korean
older generation people
but they their parents spoke english
oh you're all of your own speak english
uh
well actually
the ones who cannot speak korean are the
ones their parents can speak english
so the other ones who cannot uh who can
speak korean their parents uh their
i don't think they spoke english at home
well how how good is their english is
really good
uh i mean i yeah i mean they could have
fluent conversa i mean it's not like
they had accent but they could totally
have a full-on conversation without
speaking korean
oh really yeah were they were they
educated here in the states part i think
so i don't know about my uncle
uh but i remember he was more on the
quiet side but my aunt the on who spoke
who speaks english she studied in
germany
and so
she was she started for what was she
doing in germany i think she was in med
school she was she she was a nurse
so she started there and came over here
in chicago and i think that's when
my mom came later on when that aunt was
like kind of settled she
was able to like bring other sisters in
so she's been around for a while
that's crazy you're you're on live in
germany
apparently
yeah have you ever asked her about that
no
because i knew about it later on
that's fat i want to see photos of her
in germany i know me too i want to see
all that stuff that's not very common
yeah i mean we should go and see her
she's like
she's really busy so i heard
busy doing what she's retired but she's
very involved in a lot of things she's
like i don't know if she is right now
but then before she was in like dance
class she was doing like a host family
program like people would come to her
place
um
she knows her community very well she
does i mean
the lady doesn't drink at all but she
knows how to party
you know what's crazy like as i get
older i always think about death a lot
right like death is something that
always circles around in my head
like i think not so much my death but
everybody around me because there's like
stages in your life right because i
think about like when i was a kid so
when i was a kid
the
immediate family was different than my
immediate family now right because time
goes by things change so for me in
thanksgiving it was
me
my mom
my
dad my brother
and then it was um abe's family
uh
abe is an old family friend of mine
uh they have uh two kids as well
and then my mom's uh best friend and
then the husband so we would spend
christmas together because we didn't
have a lot of immediate family here all
of our relatives live out in korea
and um during thanksgiving or christmas
his um his brother would also come and
he would bring his family too and then
we would spend one of the holidays
together because he has a half brother
were you guys living on close by
yes so they used to be neighbors but
they moved like 30 minutes out but we
would always have it at their house we'd
have thanksgiving at their house
and then my cousin my older cousin he
had his own family
which is you know my aunt and uncle and
then his younger brother and then he
also had his wife uh katie and they
would have their separate christmases in
separate thanksgiving so i would usually
just go to two and i would cycle those
in and out right because they don't
really know they don't really know abe's
family so they would have two separate
things so i would spend two different i
would have two thanksgivings and two
christmases to go to yeah so the early
christmas i would go with my my cousins
and then i would go to uh abe's uh abe
abe joseph and sam's uh christmas party
after well all this stuff changed right
because they moved out of sacramento
they live near l.a now
and um
[Music]
my cousin mike moved out the jersey and
my other cousin moved to texas so this
idea of like what the chris the holidays
are starts to slowly change consistently
yeah and then that gets me to think
about as i get older and then you know
you know we have kids and then we start
our own family
like there's gonna be moments where my
identity or my thought of what christmas
is when it comes to the people gathering
together aren't gonna change because
yeah later on my mom's gonna pass away
my dad's gonna pass away and they won't
be around for these christmases and now
there's a new definition of what
christmas is going to be and it's kind
of crazy because in my thought like even
now as i get older i still have this
weird idea of that you know mom and dad
are always going to be here right so
every time i go back home i expect to
eat certain food i expect to have
certain conversations
and
i think when they retire they're
probably going to sell that house and
this is a house that i grew up in my
whole life and i'll never be able to
step foot in that house again
it's it's crazy how fast time goes by
when you're older when you're young
everything feels so [ __ ] slow you
almost can't wait for it to be a new day
so you could hurry up and get to summer
school or you can't wait for the summer
to have vacation as you get older you
just you're begging for time to slow
down yeah like you want time to slow
down every time time goes by i'm like
[ __ ] another day win
oh [ __ ] someone said this that as you
age think of it as like the speed
thermometer is that what it's called the
speed thermometer
uh the speedometer
speedometer
yeah
that um
it's like that's how fast your time is
passing by so like when you're in 30s
versus when you're in 80s that's how
fast the day is going best buy for you
so in your tens it's a lot slower than
in your 30s in your 50s and in the 80s
90s you're just like going
the day goes by so fast it's crazy
because i know that time's going by fast
right and even right now like we don't
have kids but imagine we have kids and
that's a whole new chapter that starts
and the way that we used to change and
be we have to change our behaviors now
based on this child and it's kind of
crazy just that kind of stuff even
frightening frightens me too it's like
yo
that's another chapter that's going to
start not that i'm scared of it per se
but it's like it's scary about
time just scares me how fast it goes
away
you you do have limited times to do
things
um
not to say that you know just because
you're older you can't do everything
that you want but as you get older
things just aren't the same anymore
right your priorities shift your energy
isn't the same like your priorities
isn't the same so yeah it's just
there are more things that are happening
in your life when you get older that
it's not as simple as it was when you're
a kid to get things done i think the
craziest thing even something small like
i've been working on these graphic
designs for this new store that i'm
opening out in um
hawaii right i spent the whole day
working on it and the whole day is gone
just like that and i always think about
time and the reason why i always
thinking about time and how important it
is because i think i've said this on
this podcast multiple times is that you
never ever get time back there's a lot
of stuff that you can do you can mend
relationships you can do all this other
stuff but time is something you never
get back
the moment
as we're talking right now time moves
forward constantly and i know that
sometimes i get sad because uh i feel
like at times i'm not capitalizing on
the time that i have that i should be
doing more
and that's the stuff too that's always a
constant reminder for me to kind of work
for these things like the only reason
why i even care about money now is so
i'm comfortable later on right because i
think about my parents my parents always
had to work they're still working at the
same store till this day and they're
retiring next year but they've spent
now
i think they had that store
31 years now
31 years of their life they spend at
that store
and that store is going to be not in
your life
exactly i can't visit that store anymore
after next year that store i can't see
it anymore
you know as you're saying this as you're
talking about like your house your store
how that was always there since you
could ever remember
the first place that i thought where i
was like do i have a place anything like
that the first place i thought of was
actually my uh aunt's house that where
we celebrate a lot with christmas and
thanksgiving because it's
the only place that actually stuck
around for i mean it's still there till
this day
and because in i moved around so much
and my environment is always changing
that there's no
there's not much of attachment like that
when there's like when it's over it's
just over for me
so it's weird to think
it's fascinating that you're seeing a
place where you know that you grew up
and there's so much history there that
it's gonna go away
yeah it's it's it's sad
like that's just all gonna
but i'm a very sentimental person when
it comes to even like personal bonds
that i have right
i mean i have that too i've kept friends
since i was in elementary school and i
still had those same friends till this
day
like bonds and loyalty mean a lot to me
right so
that
in conjunction with memories that i have
of a place is also very important to me
um
even that store when i was younger i
hated going to that store i spent a fat
chunk of my life in my high school and
junior high working at that [ __ ]
store and i hated being there because i
wanted to have a normal life like every
other kid did but when you know when
you're younger you can't really
empathize with what your parents are
going through they needed help but i
just wanted to be a kid so i used to i
used to resent that store and at the
time my brother hardly ever worked there
because my parents felt that education
was his priority and that he was smarter
than me so he needed to be in school and
this was my back-up plan in case i
dropped out of high school so they made
me work the store and he never had to
work it so it caused like this tension
and rift and those are all these
negative emotions that's attached to the
store but because
that store was also a big
part of my growth as a human being
i'm going to miss it even though i hated
being there
like the smell
the
[Music]
all the weird stories that i got from
being in the store all the life
experiences
all that type of stuff
i get to keep with me in my memories but
i can't go back and visit it again
because once they're gone it's gonna be
something else and we won't be able to
visit that place anymore which makes me
sad well because it's not going to be
there
there's not going to be there and the
reason why our store still works till
this day is not because there aren't
other places where you can get these
products it's because of the
relationship my parents have with the
people in the neighborhood
our clientele for the store isn't new
customers
it's all returning clientele-based
i say like 80 to 90 of people that come
to the store are people who've been
going there since they were little kids
that's the only reason why my parents
have a living is because they developed
a strong relationship with the people in
the neighborhood a lot of stores in that
area disappeared because they never did
that
what what was it that your parents did
nothing they just always treated people
according to how they treated them so
people were good to my parents my
parents were always good to them i think
one of the stuff that my parents that i
saw my mom do a lot is that for example
there would be some times where
certain stylists
they don't have money
like they don't have the cash on them
and it doesn't matter i don't know how
they're i'm not managing their finances
but they don't have the cash on hand and
so what my mom would do for people who
were stylists and they were struggling
to pay a bill but they would always come
and buy products she would let them take
stuff on and make a tab
which she
not nobody does that at a retail store
yeah they go oh you come a lot i know
you need like you need the barber side
you need you need like a couple of stuff
you need this clipper or whatever you
always come anyways here let's build a
tab for you and then these people
for years and my mom would just put
write it on a receipt and then chat and
she only did it for a few people that
were really loyal customers but these
people too they always came back and
they paid off their tab good every
[ __ ] time they paid off their tab
there was a couple of people who just
bounced but i think they just were going
through some tough times and they just
couldn't get back and so they left
but
those same customers come back
and they always paid back their tab and
my mom has developed this relationship
over time constantly and it's kind of
crazy to see that so these are also like
the great memories that i have with them
and when as time goes by that memory is
going to be gone so it's like well not
memory it's just that i won't be able to
go back there is it hard for you to let
it go
i don't think it's hard for me to let go
it's just it just makes me sad because
i'm i i find value in memories and bonds
and relationships it's how i've always
navigated that's why i don't
the only people that you see that walk
into this home unless it's like a
podcast guest or something are people
that i develop strong bonds with you
don't ever get i don't ever introduce
you to people that are acquaintances i
don't ever introduce you to people who
are cursory friends you only get to meet
people who are really close to me unless
we're outside on the streets and
somebody says what's up
right other than that you rarely see
this i mean how often do i ever bring
guests into this house not very often
because i like to
i like to nurture the bonds that i have
and on the other end it's like if i have
a really strong friendship with somebody
and it ends up really bad it also hurts
me double fold right only one time in my
life and you know about this person one
time in my life have i ever felt like
somebody
i somebody did something where it was
out of character
right and the crazy thing is is like i
had to think about it too it's like
oh i don't even really know this person
you know
but this person somehow infiltrated
their way into my life through other
friends and i kind of instead of
listening to my gut when i first met
this person yeah i decided to give this
person the benefit of doubt
because they were so close to some of my
other friends
and it turns out that my gut feeling was
right
and
i was like
it
it's not so much hurts but it pisses me
off that i didn't follow my gut when it
comes to meeting people and every time
i've met somebody and i've created a
strong bond nothing bad has ever
happened
this is the one time in my 30 years of
living that this actually happened so
it's like
what in the [ __ ] where did this go wrong
i've never been backstabbed by somebody
like this right
by somebody who i thought was really
really close to me yeah people who i
just met it's understandable i don't
really [ __ ] know you and then i had
to look back and say oh actually these
behaviors have been here for a very long
time and i was the one that decided to
put my guard down because i gave them
the benefit of the doubt yeah and that's
when it's like oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was i thinking and the
crazy thing is like i'm the type of
person if we're close and you wrong me
if this person died tomorrow
i literally would smile and be happy oh
my god that's how but to me
that's how important bonds are to me you
do something that is so downright dirty
and you're you're the the cul your true
colors are you're a piece of [ __ ] person
and i allowed you in my circle number
one i'm disappointed in myself but
number two because i
value friendship and trust so much that
when you deny that you to me you are
dead so if you die tomorrow i'd be
completely happy because now i know in
my mind that you don't get the [ __ ] over
somebody else because and this person
too [ __ ] over so many other people i
just couldn't see it for myself
so then going back to the um
like your home and the store would that
be your first so you had your
breakup and like friendship issue
what about so would this be your first
thing that you have to let go then
that you've held on to
it would be the store i mean at the
store i mean the house that we the first
thing because
i mean for you like you said is hard for
you to understand because you you i have
an idea of it because like i've also you
know when i go place to
go back to places that i lived or have
memories you know going back to japan
for example i have it brings memories
but it's not as long as like my whole
childhood like yeah i don't have that
you've traveled so often and you've
moved from so many homes like we lived
three places we number no four
when we first came to states we lived in
these apartments it's out in the hood
right in sacramento off mack road and uh
near like oak park
and if you guys know back in the navy of
sacramento like those areas were super
bad back in the day
um and then uh we moved into these
duplexes
right and then from those duplexes we
moved into this house which is actually
really close to where i live now
um and then from that house that we were
renting my parents bought a home and
then we stayed there and that's where
we've been since i was
eight years old
so
i've spent a fat chunk of my life there
so it is your first place that you're
letting go the longest two oh for sure
the longest do you want to keep that
house
i don't know if it's smart to keep the
house just to keep it though
you know
it's not in the best it's not in the
best name it's the most hoarding thing
to do yeah it's like i mean it's not in
the best neighborhood too and then
there's so much money i would have to
put into it to fix it up
so it's like i would on i would want to
buy the house if if the property value
was great and it's going to go up but
that neighborhood is going to [ __ ]
it's pretty it's pretty kind of it's
kind of hood so by college i think one
of the
college uh when i was in berkeley i was
at an apartment and that was probably
one of the longest place that i've
stayed that when i was graduating
before
uh we left what i did is with a actual
digital camera is that i've recorded me
walking into the apartment and opening
the room the bathroom and showing like
how the environment was because i didn't
want to forget it
so that's
that's the most that i could relate to
is that because it's been such short
time of experience and that in all the
places that i live that i forget so the
only way for me to remember is to record
it
for you i'm sure it'll be like oh it's
so clear in my head how it was
yeah i i i remember
every little
nook and
uh scratches i've made and
i punched in the wall all that other
stuff i know everything about that house
so it's it's kind of crazy to think that
probably like a year from now
i won't be able to step foot in that
home again
blows my mind
i did like that house it was nice
it's just i mean it's
the house is damn you're falling apart
sometimes but it's like it's just a
house that you grew up in is very
there's like i think the warmth to a
home is it's all based on the people
that are in it
so it i've definitely been to other
people's homes where it feels a little
sterile
um and i think it's because of the
relationship that some of my friends
have with their parents it's not it's
not close so the house just feels like
not comfortable yeah the home just feels
like a house but the house doesn't feel
like a home right
and it's like oh this is
not very cozy there's something off
about it like you don't feel
you don't feel like this is a place that
you could grow up in or you don't feel
like there was like really people living
in here
you know
it feels like a place where people just
go in to sleep and then wake up and they
leave
i'm trying to think i'm like
did i have any places like that
because i most of my time in my
childhood i actually stayed at like at
my friend's house a lot not like to
sleep but throughout the day because uh
my purple and my parents were working so
i would have like a friend's parents
pick me up when they pick up their kids
and then my parents would pick me up at
their place yeah so mom always at their
you know what now i remember
it's not that it's sterile but it was
literally breaking down when there was a
huge hole in the house and
i was wondering why there's a hole and i
see my friend
it's kind of sad though i see my friend
she had this jar of cheese that she was
eating she had a parrot as a pet well
that's cool the parrot was eating the
cheese with her in the same jar
and then the mom came around and the mom
saw my friend
giving milk to a stray cat and the mom
got so mad she raised her hand
and she thought she was raising her hand
to her kid but she was actually coming
after me
and then it
but it hit her that oh my god you're not
my daughter so she turned around and
went to her kid but
that was probably the most like
whoa this is not a comfortable house to
come back what is wait what was her
what was her ethnicity asian korean
it was a korean girl yeah
really yeah cause she was this really
this was in middle school she was this
jolly girl i really enjoyed having her
around she's very bubbly and i don't
know what happened but i ended up going
to her place
and it was a little bit different
and then she got her jar she was eating
cheese and then i saw a bird and i was
like that's
that shouldn't be the right thing for us
a single mom and a single kid and then
one kid i think it was a single mom
and i think
yeah there was a bit of a story behind
that mom
oh that's crazy yeah that was i think
and obviously nobody knows at school or
anything she doesn't say much but
i almost wanted to take her to my place
not that that would do anything but it
felt like
it was so it felt so unsafe being there
what happened to her i have oh uh she's
married
she's happy beautiful kids yeah she's
doing well oh well her story ended well
yeah thank god we were i was actually
really happy to hear that because i
didn't know what happened but through
friends uh i was i got the update that
she has a happy life
it was it's a happy ending for her man
you was crazy too especially because you
you get to when you meet people and you
hear their their backstory and i'm
pretty sure she's fine but everybody who
has those type of traumas it always
seeps out you know there's always stuff
that we don't know that's going on
behind closed doors oh yeah of course
i'm gonna say anything bad about it but
i'm saying like that's stuff that you
know
ptsd i'm sure ptsd it's hard to impact
and you know
because probably maybe because she'd
gone through that more reason to
suppress
any of that to happen we all do that
stuff yeah i think the hard part is is
when i get older it's like
i'll meet some of these people who are
i don't [ __ ] like them right but then
i hear about their story and it goes
that's why i know why you're such a
[ __ ] weirdo it's because of all the
[ __ ] that you [ __ ] went through you
know and then how you've processed it
and you didn't process it at all and you
know you don't want to confront these
things but also as an adult too what
people don't understand when when it
comes to empathy empathy also has a
limit
like i can only empathize up to a
certain point to the
to the point to the brink before i sock
you in the [ __ ] face like at a
certain point you still have to take
personal responsibility for how you
behave towards others and how and how
you say things to people and if it's
always like well you didn't know how i
grew up cool i don't i also don't have
to give a [ __ ] about you too yeah right
yeah i it's
i think
more or less i don't know if it's this
is one of those things that because
we're
quarantined
and
for example my life is that i'm
quarantined i work from home i don't see
people and i'm in my you know getting
into my mid-30s now
and this is where really adult life is
should be happening and
i don't know if
i feel like people around me around this
age
uh are now
kind of grabbing out these ptsd that
they've been suppressing i don't know if
it's called adult trauma or
they can't handle it anymore so now it's
coming now or because
quarantine therapy life you know their
therapy is such a huge advocate it was a
big reason though for a lot of people
because you think so well because we
don't have any more distractions when it
comes to these thoughts these are
thoughts that we always think about but
when you can distract yourself with a
lot of high endorphins stuff like for
example hanging out with your friends
enjoying drinks going out clubbing
um hang out with your co-workers
traveling
whatever that it is when you're left
alone in a room with just your thoughts
those thoughts start to eat up at you
and it starts to just
and you can't even process it sometimes
you know what the [ __ ] is this like have
i always been like this am i always
thinking about this stuff are these
behaviors normal and then you know you
start going into a [ __ ] spiral
um i think for me in quarantine i feel
pretty okay because
i do that stuff anyways like i'm always
sitting here picking at why i do things
why i behave a certain way
and even at the end of the year
what i do is i write out my goals and i
see what i want to do and i see what i
want to change and how i want to move
forward i think for me it's kind of
normal like i've been even when i first
started doing youtube i was in a room by
myself always thinking about these
random thoughts
you know nowadays i don't think as much
i honestly just kind of turn my mind off
and i blank out and i just start walking
or swing in front of my office right and
only because like
i'm not it's not so much that i'm
suppressing thoughts is that i've kind
of learned to focus my thoughts on
things that matter more not and not just
focus on everything and it's something
that a lot of people don't think that's
good yeah so it's it's it's a fault that
a lot of younger people have and
something that i used to do a lot when i
was younger everything pissed me off
everything was my business and i always
had an opinion about everything that
didn't really [ __ ] matter even if it
wasn't for entertainment purpose says
right just because i was young i always
i gave way too many [ __ ] i was giving
away [ __ ] like it was halloween candy
yeah in here you get a [ __ ] you get a
[ __ ] you get a [ __ ] everybody gets a
[ __ ] right but when you get older you
start to realize these [ __ ] that we
give
i don't have much yeah so i have to get
i have to toss it out very sparingly you
know at the points that really matter
the most because when you don't you just
stress out about this yeah
yeah well i don't know
kind of i don't know about you when
you're thinking about these important
aspects of your
life and the thoughts that you have for
it
for me because
i'm trying to do that as well like
equality over quantity
the stress is even higher and i don't
know because i'm aging as well and i
feel like time is you know as you said
time is
more or less limited as the day goes by
so the stress and the anxiety
gets so much higher
and like if i had in my 20s if i had 10
goals
now in my 30s i have five goals why is
it that it's so much harder to achieve
these five goals and why is it so much
more stressful
and i feel like i'm wasting my time
because when you're in your 20s you feel
like you have the rest of your life to
accomplish these things yeah
it comes by so fast 30s come by so fast
well that's what i'm saying like the the
i
the idea of time being something that's
very finite for human beings or just any
living organism in general starts to hit
you when you're older yeah because you
could feel age when you're in a choice
you don't feel any of that [ __ ] when i
was in my 20s i was i was fat and i was
perfectly fine
i was playing basketball i was doing all
this other [ __ ] i was playing i could
play ball for five six hours and i was
damned to 300 pounds it didn't matter
now it's so when i hit my when i was
like 28 which i'm
28 or no 20 28 i think that's when i
started losing weight
it was like 28 or 29 around there
i felt it i felt everything that i
didn't feel before
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this why do my
knees hurt so much why does my back hurt
so much what is all this stuff is
everything that i didn't pay attention
to because it was a goal of mine that i
always put in the back burner because i
felt like i always had time
and now time too it's not when we think
about time two um people go well you're
still young yeah a hundred percent
but
the quality of time and the things that
you can do when you're older are
different than women
time is actually now
really daunting me yeah it's relative to
the time that we have right so for
example you go you have all these like
cool things that you want to do but we
have to think about it in reality
what's our responsibilities
yeah because responsibility also take
away from these things too are you going
to have kids kid even having children
has a time to it i'm not telling people
that you have to stop and then you know
give up on life i'm saying that you have
to assess and re-evaluate yeah what you
want to spend your time on it still
frustrates me that corn this cova thing
has taken
at least two years of our life yeah to
be free and it it's like that those two
years and some people's ass uh
perspective like they might be nothing
but those two years that's a lot that's
a lot of time we lost that we could have
done two years is a lot that first that
first year covid where we were had to be
quarantined inside of our apartment
that right there pissed me off because
i don't like wasting this thing that i
can't get back
you know mind you it was cool you know
we we got to watch movies we got to
relax and rest but there are things that
within these two years i could have done
that we didn't get to do that yeah and
we can't get that back and so now we
have to compromise for the next
following years of like how are we going
to do certain or what are the things
we're gonna have to eliminate basically
or how are we gonna combine them or
compromise
and that's where it's like
there is us and then now there's me and
as much as there's still time i need to
figure out how i could fit it within
this
time frame
that
unfortunately that i have for myself
because i'm not always going to be just
me yeah so and i think like that's why
people always talk about you know people
who are older than us like make the most
of your time and make the most of your
days not because you should live in fear
it's because it's just something that's
very precious yeah you know people like
to tell you too you have 24 hours a day
you don't have 24 [ __ ] hours in a day
you actually don't
because we're like 10 12
yeah six to eight hours is that is what
is sleeping yeah and it is true you have
to sleep let's say six hours you sleep
right then you have 14. and then how
many hours do you work
eight minimum and you're in traffic or
no 14 right so you have 10 hours a day
that's that's what you spend your time
on you have literally ten nine to ten
hours a day
to kind of
oh you have yeah i mean no if you're
sleeping and you have 10 hours a day and
you're working eight hours
you don't have that much time yeah eight
to whatever eight to ten hours a day
typically and i think you know on on a
weekday monday through friday right and
that's really where your time is spent
yeah one of the things that everybody is
going to
should be afraid of is reaching a
certain age and looking back and saying
[ __ ] i regretted this i regretted that
you don't want to live like that
yeah
yeah
yeah well anyways guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast i hope you enjoyed this
podcast uh you can catch mariel at
merriel underscore underscore song
and you can find me at davidson comedy
everything and the genius brain podcast
every thursdays and sundays up until
january 1st which is actually coming in
about
three weeks and then we're back we're
only going to do it once a week wow um
hope you guys been enjoying this podcast
may you have blessings on pond blessings
and may the force be with you
oh okay
amen be the person your dog thinks you
are be the person
your dog thinks you are what if you
don't have your dog well then imagine
what a dog would think you are
okay we'll see you all next time